whilst the far from home trailer was
leaked after its first showing at Brazil
comic-con it was still exciting to see
all of the elements play out on screen
similar to ant-man and the wasp the
trailer is pretty low-key
in terms of the overall MCU and it's
clear that the films going forward may
have smaller self-contained stories that
slowly lead up to the main events that
doesn't mean the movies are
underwhelming either and homecoming was
a breath of fresh air to me due to its
stakes being rather miniscule in the
grand scheme of things Peter is wanting
to take a break from superheroing and
this smaller scale aesthetic perfectly
cements this I also love that the
trailer is taking risks and has
characters such as Mysterio and
hydro-man popping up as they are
definitely more for fans of Marvel as
opposed to more general audiences the
trailer reeks of fun and it's actually
refreshing in a lot of ways to see the
webhead outside of his comfort zone if
New York City wasn't a real location it
would feel like it was built for
spider-man's abilities thus taking him
out of this comfort zone allows that to
be added tension which I think perfectly
had subplot Venice is steeped in lower
buildings with the majority of it being
in water thus Peter will have to think
around the situation in order to get the
best out of it this is a smart move in
my opinion on the creators part as
Mysterio is pretty clumsy so this should
even the playing fields I love seeing
Gyllenhaal take of the role and can't
wait to see what he delivers overall
it's been a pretty good start to the air
to be a Marvel fan and the amount of new
footage we are getting has massively got
me hyped for phase 4 obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the film's
trailer so make sure that you comment
below and leave them if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of the big twist in glass
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thanks again
for take the time to watch this
I've been definition and you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]